the UK is now claiming it doesn't know
how many civilian casualties were caused
by its airstrikes in Syria in Iraq it
comes after authorities faced a wave of
criticism for claiming their actions in
the anti-isil campaign resulted in just
one civilian death it was not our
position that there has only been a
single civilian casualty as a result of
our military action what we are saying
is that we only have evidence of what we
believe to have been a single civilian
casualty according to the UK defence
ministry the Royal Air Force conducted
nearly 2,000 airstrikes during its
engagement in Syria and Iraq in 2014
resulting in the deaths of more than
4,000 ISIL fighters human rights
organization Amnesty International
released a damning report last year
accusing the coalition of failing to
acknowledge the scale of damage the
campaign caused civilians
it is completely reprehensible that the
Coalition refuses to acknowledge its
role in most of the civilian casualties
it caused we go live now to peace
campaigner Russel winning welcome to the
program
so the MOV says it wasn't claiming there
was only one civilian casualty but that
it's only found evidence of one casualty
considering there were so many
airstrikes do you buy that no not for
one second and I don't think any of your
viewers will either let's not forget the
Ministry of Defence actually only
claimed one civilian have been killed
after months and months of claiming none
they claimed that they were bombing over
and over again and not killing anyone
the truth of the matter is we are
dropping bombs on people day after day
after day and have been for years in an
area of the world where there's very
little infrastructure but it's very
little support on the ground we haven't
even got any boots on the ground so we
just have no idea of how many innocent
civilians we've killed through these
bombing raids now at the same time the
Ministry of Defence has verified that
over 4,000 ISIL fighters have been
killed in the airstrikes it claims
they're not enough boots on the ground
to verify civilian casualties why the
discrepancy exactly
completely mad isn't it just bonkers the
idea that you can no
whether someone is an ISIL fighter or a
civilian after a bomb has been dropped
on them the idea that you don't have
enough boots on the ground for one
category of people to be identified but
you do for another one I'm afraid
this just absolutely stinks of
propaganda from our government so we
will continue to support these ongoing
wars which the British public are just
fed up with we don't want to keep
bombing the Middle East endlessly we
want our troops and our planes to come
home so why do you think the UK is
finding it so difficult to release
accurate figures and do you think that
the figures will now change at this
point I don't think the figures will
change I don't think any figure that
we've been given about our involvement
in Syria Afghanistan Iraq Libya have
been accurate because we just don't know
we keep rushing into these interventions
with no idea about who we're targeting
don't forget in 2013 we wanted to go
into Syria to help President Assad and
now we're wanting to go in against
President Assad the whole thing is just
so confused this is what happens when
you made foreign policy on the hoof
rather than actually have a strategic
objectives and strategic goals the best
thing to do would be to leave the people
of Syria to have their own destiny in
their own hands and for British troops
and British planes to come back to
Britain we saw Amnesty International
repeatedly condemning the us-led
coalition for not acknowledging the
scale of civilian casualties and that
eventually forced their hand will the UK
eventually follow suit do you think well
I would certainly hope that they would
put more effort into finding out the
damage that they're causing on the
ground but again without having British
people British intelligence British
troops on the ground in Syria which I
don't think anyone wants and wouldn't be
safe for them I don't know how we can
find out how much damage we're causing
don't forget Syria has been bombed
repeatedly for what the last seven years
there's not actually that much
infrastructure left in this country the
people have suffered enough they don't
really care whether it's bombs from
Bashar al-assad or bombs from Britain or
America that are killing them they just
want to go about their daily
without being constantly bond and we
should have the decency to leave them to
do that
you